look at this look uh we have a story
from bloomberg this is funny
china pushes russia conspiracy theory
about u.s labs in ukraine russia
wouldn't just put russia i don't know
why they labeled it that way titled it
that way foreign ministry urged u.s to
name viruses stored in labs i wonder if
she has yet to call russia's military
action and invasion i bet the word
russia gets better clicks better like
internet search results than russian
that's why they did it you a fan of that
bio lab name three of their viruses
sorry yeah and this is this is literally
the same these are the same types of
headlines that we saw at the beginning
of the covid pandemic with the when
people were pushing the lab leak theory
i'll never forget the one from the
washington post when they literally said
tom cotton is repeating a conspiracy
theory about kova that has already been
debunked like this is the same exact
game plan that they did when kovitz
started with the lat when they covered
for the lab leak from china what i'm
starting to notice is when you debunk
something it doesn't mean that it wasn't
right well the difference today between
disinformation and something that's true
is only a couple weeks or months now or
days yeah well yeah or even day or even
or even days in this case bio labs
itself was a conspiracy theory yeah but
it's because what they do is
if you bring up to a journalist what's
up with these bio labs in ukraine they
immediately retreat to the mod and go
like oh u.s doesn't have bio labs in
ukraine he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa i
didn't say us right said what's up with
these bio labs so what happens is you'll
get a regular person
and like i've experienced this it's
really funny you know people shouldn't
play games because i know what i'm
talking about and i'll say something and
they'll you know there's this is a
really good example
so i'll give you a hypothetical but
because i don't want to invade i don't
want to violate anyone's privacies but
so you'll say something like did you
guys hear about you'll be at a party and
you'll be like do you hear about these
bio labs in ukraine now now they're
confirming it russia of course probably
is not happy with it and then someone
goes
there's no u.s bio labs in ukraine
you're making that up and then i'm just
like
i never said u.s a regular person though
might be like of course they're i was
reading about it and then they'll pull
up on their phone and they'll say there
are no u.s bio labs see everybody who
was wrong
that's what they'll do and people will
conflate these stories and not realize
it don't play games with me because i'm
going to be like i didn't say us my
favorite part is that that's the stuff
you talk about at parties
seriously no i'm not i am serious yeah
yeah of course i do also i walk into a
party i grab a beer like how about that
biola
everyone's like oh yeah yeah and we're
all drinking i just gotta say i really
hope they're not eating bat soup in
ukraine seriously because that's the
most logical explanation of where
biological weapons come from right you
were a conspiracy theorist if you
thought that the virus which was first
infecting people right near a biological
weapons research lab was made in a
biological weapons research lab instead
of coming from a bat so so what happens
is you've got all these labs in ukraine
and china's saying like tell us what
viruses are in it in like a month all of
a sudden there's like 12 new viruses
that emerge in ukraine and then the
mainstream media goes that was an
armadillo that wasn't ukraine's bad
infestation problem
but the sad thing is it's there it's
serious like when i was so when i was at
the daily caller back when covet first
started we were one of the first news
outlets that ran stories about the
potential for that that this virus came
from a lab and we got dinged on facebook
for it the way facebook works is the way
you get one of those fact checks on your
post is a fact checker has to write an
actual story one of their certified fact
checkers has to write a story about your
post and you get dinged and if you get a
certain amount of them you get your
account to monetize we got one for
running lab league stories like this is
the media and big tech and you know the
deep state
working together to suppress information
that they don't want the public to know
but they apologize of course right oh
well yeah eventually they you know
eventually when it all came out oh i'm
kidding they actually did that's well no
no they didn't apologize
of course they didn't apologize but when
the info finally came out that actually
there is merit to the lab league story
they stopped the censorship remember
when um that was what was that guy's
name andy stone is the guy from facebook
he's on twitter and he's like the the
hunter biden laptop story is you know
disinformation over so we're suppressing
it to make sure it can't be shared and
then twitter did and then like a month
later they're like oh that story was
real
like they they publicly brag about
suppressing pertinent information to an
election and it happens
and that guy too used to work for the d
triple c and barbara boxer and a bunch
of other democrats too so you had this
democrat comms guy who now works at
facebook talking about how they're
censoring a story that's unfavorable to
the then democrat candidate for
president you know what concerns me
right here is that there's going to be a
leak this is the narrative okay the two
biggest fears in the world right now
covid and russia they're gonna that
there's gonna be a leak in ukraine and
they're gonna blame it on russia and
it's gonna be another pandemic well so
so that's exactly what we heard with
marco rubio just in the other segment
rubio's saying there's no doubt in your
mind you know ms newlin that if there's
a biotech it is russia yes the priming
now if something happens they're like we
told you it was russia time for us to
invade marco marco
russia how conspiratorial do you want to
get very seven remember remember when uh
remember when
bill gates recently was talking about uh
weaponized smallpox yeah what was that
story again what an odd thing to talk
about yeah you wanna you wanna pull it
up real quick see if you can pull it up
there was a story where it was like bill
gates was talking about treatment for
like weaponized smallpox he's like we
speculate it would evolve from a bat
yeah well it's gonna be an animal but
this time it's a penguin
it's like these penguins
the penguins will fight back
bill gates warns of weaponized smallpox
just after fda approves his new pox drug
this is from november 29th 21
uh that was actually recently so this is
the independent
yeah so we have right here bill gates
warns of smallpox terror attacks as he
seeks research funds yeah now look this
just could could be you know him being
like i'd like money please
or maybe we should pay attention to what
powerful global elites are saying about
stuff when you have people like rubio
saying there could be a bio attack so it
would be a smallpox thing i don't know i
don't know if these things are connected
i don't like speculating i just want to
get on the record saying it now so that
in in six months if it does happen uh
people know that i was thinking it i'll
put i'll put it this way
you can you can take it the pessimistic
nefarious route and assume bill gates
knows something or we can trust bill
gates he warned us about weaponized
smallpox now we're hearing russia might
do a bio attack
dude
i know that the nih was and was bill
gates doing it oh i don't know i don't
know that's you you got to be a
government
you could get fact checked for it yeah
no but like let's let's make sure we're
accurate
was bill gates and anybody providing
funding to ego house bill and melinda
gates foundation they did i'm looking at
it now see if you can find anything so
i'll i'm gonna put it this way i'm gonna
give bill gates the benefit of the doubt
even though i don't like the guy and say
okay maybe he's right and knows
something about the potential terror
attacks yeah bill melinda gates
foundation committed a 1.5 million
dollar grant to the eco-health alliance
in 2020. see there you're you're all
right yeah you know i was just saying
just make sure you fact check it because
we got to be very precise i knew that so
i just i wanted to we were
we knew that testing
that info comes from influencewatch.org
but is that is that legitimate
i don't know how to check i don't have
let's see some non-profits watch dogs
uh
bill gates celebrates collaboration with
nih from gatesfoundation.org also is
that right
let me see they're pretty well there you
go i mean honestly it's not it's not
far-fetched to believe that bill gates
is providing um
uh is providing this you know financial
assistance to this organization i mean
he talks about vaccines oh yeah it's on
the gates foundation website well they
support india's ministry of animal
husbandry whatever so let's just go
ahead and say maybe bill gates when he
warns of smallpox terror attacks kind of
knows something we don't
i'm not saying he's malicious conspiracy
i'm saying maybe he's right maybe he's
right and we should be worried i'll just
tell you this whatever you want to
believe that there's a grand cabal
planning these things and bill gates is
involved or bill gates is a superhero
who's saving people
there seems like a risk of smallpox
terror attacks so um i i don't know what
you do do you just you know buy
emergency food and hide buy emergency
food yes i'm dropping with tunes
obviously
i'm gonna buy uh some shipping
containers and bury them and crawl into
it and
die you know what i've heard shipping
containers not the way to go though
because they cave in
yeah they're also they're not made
they're not really made to sustain uh
weight geodesic domes right
yeah but they also they leak that's the
biggest problem with them i've been
doing a lot of research on those too
okay how about
how about we get giant floating domes
well so you know what's the real
difference
you create like um when you got to live
in it you create a chamber it's like a
boat you you vacuum out the boat area of
it so it floats the real flex is not
that you go to an underground layer when
it hits the fan it's that you force your
enemies into an underground layer can we
make something strong enough to
withstand a large enough vacuum to
actually float on yeah i think it's
going to be a meta material like um aero
gel yeah like a graphene arrow gel and
then what you do is you create a bunch
of little pockets of holes inside of
this boat and then you vacuum out all
these little pockets of holes so you've
got like a light lighter than air
thing and then if it's big enough it
should be able to carry people and farms
and stuff so that it's yeah so it would
be as a whole it would be uh
it would it's it's not the mass it's the
um displacement of gases and then uh you
strap an iron thruster on it and fly it
around
what do you think something
i don't know
i don't know but
lydia i just d back to our topic or
talking about bio labs i check out the
tweet that i just dmv it's actual
reality
it's a it's a guy writing for foreign
policy and it's foreign policy.com like
you know the preeminent foreign policy
magazine and he says russia helped
create and is now actively amplifying a
conspiracy theory claiming the invasion
of ukraine is being done to destroy u.s
run bioweapons facilities and he says
the wildest part people believe it yeah
so this is from march 2nd so yeah really
a few days ago now now we know
now it's getting dr but this is the
thing it's like you know foreign policy
that's you know that's held up as like
this you know by the establishment as
this you know what's up this trustworthy
news outlet that's the title yeah this
is it false claims of u.s bio warfare
labs and ukraine grip q and going on
right well look i got no problem saying
i don't see why we have to talk about
u.s bio labs or whatever like if that's
if you want to fact check that like by
all means i'm not if ukraine has bio
labs
sounds like it's a fact because victoria
newlin said they did now the question is
is this a motivating factor for russia i
don't know because russia their demands
of of ukraine are give them donbass give
them crimea and don't join nato or the
eu right i didn't see any demands from
russia where they were like get rid of
these bio labs
so
i think the story could be a stretch to
say the least but i just love how they
they this is a trick look if you've been
watching the show for some time you know
the trick because i tell you all the
time you'll have ian
and i'll do a back flip and the media
will write did ian really do a backflip
on sunday yeah
false yeah while ian did do a backflip
it was actually at midnight on saturday
which is technically not sunday although
technically it is we rate this claim
false yeah it was 11 59 and 58 seconds
by the atomic clock standard
unfortunately for ian as clockwise it
was actually monday in australia when he
did the back flip on sunday
partly true
it's not a us lab they're ukrainian labs
and they're not bio warfare labs they're
just bio labs so if you put bio warfare
it's going to be called false too
according to the girl that you see these
games they're playing with this stuff
man i love this one
politifact just goes nuts with it
bloggers say putin bombs biden owned
villa in ukraine while hammering bio
labs and pedo rings
all right well i'm gonna give you that
one politifact that sounds like that is
a little this is the problem it's
because there will be like a guy wearing
like a nice suit and he'll be like you
know i'm concerned about these bio labs
in ukraine and then there will be like a
crazy guy with a tinfoil hat next to him
going like you're right the us is
funding them and they're speedos and
then the fact checker goes i'm gonna run
with that one or or those two people
actually hate each other in real life
but the media associates them with one
another as is the case with the infamous
conspiracy theory pyramid that i
reviewed and debunked on my channel
is you want to link people who have
basically nothing in common other than
the fact that they're questioning the
official narrative there's a comic
that's being shared by all of these
leftists and it's the weirdest thing and
it shows a guy sitting on a couch with
what appears to be his wife or something
and he's got a shirt with an american
flag and he's wearing a red hat and i'm
like gee i wonder what that supposed
symbolize and he's watching the news and
he says
russia says they're just taking back
what's rightfully theirs
and then the woman goes alaska was
russia's you know 60 years ago or
something and i'm like
is this implying that the america first
anti-interventionist populist maga
people
are
like defending
you like russia's invasion of ukraine
like i don't understand like
i don't
it's it makes no sense you you can try
to do an honest analysis of putin's
motives and reject a lot of the
propaganda coming from the warfare state
in the industrial military complex and
their lackeys in the media without
supporting putin or his invasion right
well tim to your point what they're
doing is exactly what you say they can't
find anyone in real life who actually
supports putin they can't find
republicans who support putin so they
have to create this little comic they're
this is the whole of twitter is
imagining someone and then getting mad
at that person right like that person
literally doesn't exist but you're gonna
sling those narrows at him because it's
easier the best the best they can do is
find republicans who putin supports at
least according to them right exactly
they're trying they're really trying and
it's kind of sad because
there are actually real things that we
could be working toward fixing together
but no it has to be russia and even
though we don't have any problems that
need fixing right now yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you